مشهد لم يسبق له مثيل في تاريخ البرازيل
الالف من عشاق اسطوره كره القدم اتسون
ارانتيسننتو بلي تداعوا الى مهبط موهبته
ناديه التاريخي سانتوس
الملك كيف لا يكون لقب البرازيليين له وقد
احضر لهم الذهب الى بلدهم ثلاث مرات وبنى
مجدا لن ينسوه
لنا هو وجه البرازيل وفخرها ملك ليس له
مثيل واسطوره لن تتكرر
نحو النظره الاخيره تزود المحبون بكل ما
يربطهم به من ذكريات واحضروها معهم للحظه
الوداع
تخرين بتفرده بتسجيل اكثر من 1000 هدف في
تاريخه
في الكليه يحمل صوره موقعه له مع الاسطوره
الراحل ماتت عنده اغلى ذكر في حياته
الصوره التقطناها معا عندما كنا في الكليه
وكتب عليها بخط يده الجميل وتوقيعه احييك
جونيور اهديك حضنا كبيرا بالله هذه كنز
بالنسبه لي
ملعب شهد على اداءه السحري وحركاته
الاستثنائيه سجي يا جثمان بيليه محاطا
لعائلته الصغيره والكبيره وباقي جسده
ساكنا هذه المره لاربع 24 ساعه متواصله لم
يتوقع فيها حضور محبيه لحظه واحده من
شخصيات رياضيه وسياسيه وممثلين دول من
مختلف انحاء العالم خاله المدرجات من
المشجعين وحل مكانها رقمه الملكي واستمر
اق وجمهوره من نعشه طوال يوم كامل ليكون
اخرهم الرئيس البرازيلي لول ده سيلفا الذي
انهى حفله تنصيبه ليحضر حفله تابين من
يعتبره صديقهم
حمل النعش بعدها الى جنازه تاريخيه جالت
شوارع سانتوس التي غصت بالمحبين ومرت نحو
منزل والدته قبل ان يصل جثمانه الى مثواه
الاخير
في مقبره مدينته سانتوس حيث قضى جل مسيرته
الكرويه الحافله بالاهداف والبطولات
والارقام القياسيه لاعبا في ناديها وعاش
حياته بين ازقتها يدفن الاسطوره الراحل
بلاي تاركا خلفه ارسال رياضيا وحضاريا
وانسانيا لا يموت
حسن مسعود الجزيره سانتوس